dans ses murs depuis plus de 200 ans vit
l'âme du lion lusine d'hérimoncourt
berceau de la famille peugeot
là où tout a commencé va définitivement
fermer ses portes
175 salariés devront déménager vers
sochaux vesoul et peut-être mulhouse
tous devraient être reclassés
effectivement on ad d accompagnement à
faire dans ce sens là nous avons mis en
place des entretiens individuels avec
chacun d'entre nous avons maintenant une
vision des souhaits de mobilité tant
professionnelle que géographique entre
vesoul mulhouse où sochaux on est porté
par le succès de nos modèles qui donne
une activité forte sur un site qui est
pas très loin à dix kilomètres de là et
qui nous offre des perspectives de
reclassement à chacun
les archives de la marque seront
toujours conservé sur une partie des 28
mètres carrés du site des rimes en cours
mélusine
elle doit trouver de nouveaux occupants
deux candidats se sont déjà déclarés
adecco formation qui souhaite installer
une école des métiers l'automobile est
un industriel allemand sous traitant
automobile ou help qui travaille avec la
suisse ces deux projets sont en cours de
documentation a été partie prenante la
préfecture la région la pma pour pouvoir
aller encore plus loin et d'autres
projets sont en cours d'instruction pour
préparer la suite des rimes en cours
d'ici 12 à 18 mois l'abandon cuisine
originelle sera consommé un crève coeur
pour les anciens d'hérimoncourt bien on
comprend pas trop avec tous les
bénéfices qui ont été faits et puis ils
font qu'on ferme un site comme le nôtre
quoi pour transférer une activité à 70
kilomètres d'ici puis bon en priorité à
sochaux ce sera le montage démontage
véhicule donc des gens qu'on monte des
moteurs des boîtes de vitesses qui vont
se retrouver à remonter des voitures
donc ça va les changer complètement il y
aura de la formation mais c'est sûr que
ça va les changer
la route est encore longue avant de
pouvoir att la création de nouveaux
emplois hérimoncourt il faudra aussi
entreprendre quelques travaux sur le
site classé en partie zones inondables
[Musique]